thrown hens those those rocks are
nowhere in the region mm-hmm they were
carted from somewhat they found a place
where those rocks were would have been
mined removed and yeah those are some
big-ass rocks yeah as are the one but
it's not less impressive because they're
just big like what the thing about the
pyramids is so impressive is the
precision and the sheer numbers two
million our best hunters hundred
thousand stones our best understanding
of Stonehenge is that it's a functioning
Observatory that can actually predict
eclipses so did I get just good yeah
bitch-slap you there solstice they have
there are holes that are not stones but
they're 56 holes which is three times
the the serous which is the cycle of
eclipses of the matching of the orbits
of the Sun and the moon in the sky the
paths of the Sun and the moon in the sky
and when they match up you get in
Eclipse is there is this an observatory
guy named that's absolutely what it is
there's a book published in the 1970s by
a guy named David Dawkins it's not
Richard Dawkins but it's another one of
these Hawking's Richard Hawkins Richard
Hawkins Hawking Hawking Hawking's
damn what I'm dudes damn what well we
got our top crack researchers here just
look up the taliban's book with
stonehenge decoded just look up the
title a book anyhow it's highly
convincing and we all were all there
with it there's no it's essentially just
a study of the position of the stones in
relationship to the where the okay
Gerald Gerald Hawkins thank you yeah
Stonehenge decoded so he visited
Stonehenge as a kid at age fifteen on an
expedition and he was the expedition
head oh wow yeah so how lucky for you
yeah it was it was good and that stuck
with me which is why I named this
phenomenon in Manhattan where the Sun
sets along the stress yeah yeah so so I
named it Manhattan hen
sort of harkening back to my early days
thinking about the alignment of the Sun
and structures that we might build
because so twice a year for those
viewers or listeners who don't know
twice a year the Manhattan street grid
which is not perfectly aligned
north-south the Manhattan street grid
will that the Sun will set exactly on
the grid and in a grip and what's up
there now that image what's not obvious
is that picture is taken along a street
that is itself three miles long and then
you're crossing a Hudson River and then
there's New Jersey on the other side so
people try to zoom in on it but really
what you really should do is zoom out
from it and then you get the vanishing
point on it so yeah all those are zoom
zoomed in let's go to yeah that one
looks more like like my photo I go back
to that other one yeah see so so that's
on 34th Street the one you see now and
then you get this sparkling effect that
happens twice a year try to be that sort
of crazy wild light effect yes it looks
yes Photoshop dolls yeah there's an
image on his Instagram that is linked on
my Instagram the most recent photos okay
there he goes oh there's you with the
cell that's a selfie right so come on
down for a fro oh yeah
that's strong that was my first cell
phone yeah I was 14 for let me see it
was 90 probably 1974 Wow
so I would have been 15 I think I've
been 14 or 15 so your path of curiosity
was said oh that goes back very early
right but that's nothing what we're
looking for here it's good but that one
think it is so that though there's
another one but go back to all of them
at the rivers Wow zoom back out it's you
see all the pictures there go to the
bottom left there you go okay that might
be the first ever Manhattanhenge photo
what is that from I took that in 2001
right - and it got published in 2002
before September 11th this is July I
took it before September 11th right
right and then I had a means to publish
it
right then the notice that it's a green
light and traffic is ready to knock me
over so so no one is in the streets
doing this but now there are tens of
thousands of people that pour into the
streets on these days we post what day
you get Manhattanhenge from the American
Museum of Natural History my day job and
then that goes out the press gets it and
tens of thousands of people spin with
the street blocking traffic and if you
think of all the ways traffic gets
blocked in your day yeah like all it was
too many of them by yourself it's
interesting it's great yeah so that's
what it has become holding up phones but
it's all because I went to stone hands
yeah so it's a it's also a observatory
so this was it you that name this yeah
yeah damn check yeah coins coins I would
say coined it yeah Manhattan hinge
because the buildings are like hinges
the hinge is a stone is a vertical stone
there's a vertical structure if you made
a stone it's a stone hinge